[Music]
former white house physician current
texas congressman ronnie jackson is
calling on
president sippy cup joe biden to undergo
a cognitive test you might recall donald
trump did
and passed with flying colors and by the
way then to share the results with you
the american people here to explain
republican congressman and doctor from
texas ronnie jackson
all right you saw what happened at the
g7
we've been watching this unfold and then
you see these flashes of real anger
you know are you a junkie you know come
on man
and what happened with caitlin collins
do you suspect what many americans
suspect that he's in a
cognitive he's cognitively weak and in
decline
absolutely sean you know after this most
recent embarrassing
performance overseas i thought it was
time to come out we can't sit on this
any longer i've been saying this for a
year and a half sean
i took care of three presidents over 15
years in the white house
including being the physician of the
president for both barack obama and
donald j
trump and you know i know what the
rigors of this job are both
physically and cognitively it's
demanding and and after this performance
and we've been seeing this for a year
and a half now i've been saying that joe
biden is not
he's not physically or cognitively fit
to be our president right now
and i just think that he's not inspiring
confidence in the american people
he's not inspiring confidence in our
allies overseas and more importantly
sending the wrong message to our
adversaries overseas this is a dangerous
situation right now i feel like we
really need to know what's going on sean
i think that if you remember the the
mainstream media
and the far left and the democrats they
were they were relentless in their
pursuit of me
when i was taking care of president
trump just demanding that he have a
cognitive test that he'd have a physical
exam that included a cognitive test
they said that every president should
have that it should be the new standard
that we should know that our
commander-in-chief and our head of state
is
is capable of leading the nation and so
we did we submitted to that president
trump as you mentioned he did
he hit a perfect score on his cognitive
test and outstanding performance
and i i'm just saying now i'm saying
that is the new standard
the precedent has been set and i'm
asking joe biden and his medical team
to get out there and to get this
physical exam done get this cognitive
testing done and get the results back to
the american people
we need to know that we can trust our
president and we need to know that he's
in charge of what's going on
and that someone else is not pulling the
strings from behind the scene because
that's what it looks like is happening
right now
you know i know some of it you can laugh
at but when you look at the real side of
it
there's a real serious side to this
whole thing that is actually frightening
um i agree with you dr jackson part of
something something is
obviously very off i don't know what it
is i'm not a medical doctor
i won't play one on tv let's see what
happens thank you sir
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else